hello everyone I didn't think I would do
any more videos today but vastly once
you did do it impossible today in the
World Cup as if you've seen my previous
video I said that event you've managed
to draw a game against Gramlich with the
white pieces and that he had a
tremendous task in front of him today he
had to play against Vladimir Kramnik
with the black pieces and well this is
the only reason why I'm doing another
video today I do want to show you this
brilliancy it won't you played so let's
see this game this is round three of the
World Cup so the second game against
chronic chronic is white and avenge is
black we have E for c6 by a van took the
caro-kann defense we have d4 d5 e
capture Sun defy the exchange variation
C capture Sun d5 and Bishop to d3 we
have a Knight to c6 c3 Knight to f6 and
the bishop to F for the Rubinstein
variation of the caro-kann Bishop to g4
now attacking whites Queen Queen to b3
now with the attack on this b7 pawn and
event took place Quinta c8
defense defense the pawn away overnight
to D to e 6a Knight G to f3 the Bishop
to e7 Kramnik castles and Bishop to age
five in one trip is preparing Bishop g6
to exchange this Bishop on d3 we have a
rotator you won by chronic and Bishop to
g6 we have captures and now you want to
capture sweet eh pawn of course and he
doesn't get this open file for his rook
so we have h4 by kramnik a6 and we have
a c4 and here Avant you played a5 we
have a 3 and a 4 by1 Queen to d3 and now
we want to castles and we have c5 and
well in this position it's not that easy
to find a move for white what I mean
white could play something like Bishop
to gee maybe Bishop to g5 or
Rock the c1 you know just putting a rock
on a file that will soon open up but
chronic decided to place a c5 and
imagine will will show that this was a
mistake
it might should immediately place b6 as
this back
spawn isn't really useful here and well
it's really not doing anything so he
decides to get rid of it temporarily
Cromley captures he captures on v6 and
we have going to be seven now attacking
this pawn here and well there's really
not a lot of ways a chronic can defend
this pawn he does have this Bishop to c7
or maybe maybe between to b5 but if
Queen to b5 simply rook to a5 and the
Queen has to go back and then eventually
will recapture the pawn so after this is
going to be 7 move chronic played Bishop
to c7 and it does seem like this is very
unpleasant for black but event will show
that it's it's really not
it might replace Knight to d7 now
attacking the b6 bond we have worked a
c1 we have rook F to c8 by Iran took b4
event chronic is hoping for b5 but you
want to place a cap to some b3 we can
capture some b3 and we have
Bishop captures here on a3 if I sure
could have played maybe rook captures an
a3 but this would run run into some
trouble if rook captures an a3 then the
this Queen to be five move is very
unpleasant as there's a double attack on
this knight on c6 if he moves then this
night here isn't protected so he would
have to play something like night to be
eight and this wouldn't really be it
would be a pretty bad position 41 should
be much of it doesn't want to do this so
after a queen capture some b3 he played
Bishop captures on v3 on a 3-story we
have rook to c3 now preparing to double
up on the C file and event took place
Bishop to e7 and this is a very nice
move at as it creates a very nice
outpost and before for this knight on c6
Cromley glass-plate rook F 2 c1 now
doubling up and attacking this knight on
c6 and they want to place night to b4
and this is a beautiful night and before
and nothing can oppose him well not yet
anyway
we have nice to e5 we have Knight
captures Bishop captures and rook
captures on c3 Queen captures on c3 and
now Queen captures am b6 and
eventually gets his pawn back and he is
up upon ok this is a double pawn but
doesn't really matter why doesn't really
prove anything with this c5 idea a
chronic plays the knight to f3 we have
Queen to d8 we have Queen to b3 rook the
c8 event you of course wants to exchange
Brookes
rook to a-1 and now rook the c4 and this
rook to c4 is now guarding this night
and now there really is a threat of
capturing this h4 pawn so far it
couldn't be couldn't have been captured
as this night would have been hanging so
we have g3 now defending this h4 pawn
and Queen to c8 preparing a rope to c1
check and exchanging Brooks so we have a
King to g2 not allowing that Knight to
c6 attacking the bishop on e5 Quinta b5
and now we have a bishop to f8 we rook
to a four and now event Chuck does
exchange rooks rook captures an a for
Queen captures an have on a four and
night the b4 we have Queen to be 5 and
now Queen to c2 and this is a this is a
great move as it comes with the idea of
night to d3 and it will be it would have
been and it will be unstoppable to
defend f2 if eventual plays Knight to b3
so gromek has to stop this he plays
Queen to f1 we have Queen to e4 now this
is a beautiful central I swear for for
the black queen and the night here is
pinned things are looking good for a von
Schuch we have Queen to e1 now preparing
a chronic does offer the exchange of
Queens but first you want to place f6
now getting rid of this Bishop and
improving the structure of his own pawns
we have Bishop to c7 and now nice to see
- and now well Kramnik could play
something like Queen to d1 maybe
avoiding to exchange Queens but he
decides to exchange Queens so we have
Queen captures on e4 d captures on e4
Knight to d2 attacking this efore pawn
and now f5 and well this these pawns are
just beautiful they are all on light
squares
kramnik as a dark square bishop so it's
not they don't really care about this
bishop at all and now we're we're
entering the endgame and a bunch of
starts the grinding he plays chronic
plays Knight to b3 defending this pawn
on d4 and we have nights the e1 check
this is a great idea behind choke King
to f1 and Knight to f3 and as you'll see
this maneuver is was crucial for this
endgame as now the night is an f3
protected by this e for pawn and there
is nothing that can oppose this knight
on e4 well this night could oppose it
but this knight cannot move as this d4
pawn will be captured by this night so
we have team to e2 came to f7 he want to
immediately starts improving the
position of his own king we have Bishop
to b6 now kramnik does defend this pawn
so now he's preparing night 2 d2 to
exchange this powerful Knight but if one
shoe doesn't allow it he plays Bishop to
b4 and now Knights to d2 is no longer
possible we have King to e3 and team to
e8 even chip has to find some way to get
his King deeper into the position Bishop
to c5 offering the exchange but even
cook refuses Bishop to a3 we have King
to f7 Bishop to d6 King to f6 Bishop to
c7 King to e7 Bishop to be 8 and now
Bishop to b2 now
this Knight d2 move is possible but
again it's not really because then again
Knight captures d4 so 92 really doesn't
accomplish anything so we have Bishop to
f4 King to d8 and now Bishop to d6 Frank
doesn't allow event to get into the
position he's threatening Bishop to f8
this will win this g7 point but as Iran
Chuck will show this g7 point is really
irrelevant for this end game he does
play king 37 we have a bishop to f8 and
now King to c6 Bishop captures and g7
and King to d5 and well it's I mean look
at this powerful King on d5 here this
really a small price to pay this doubled
pawn on g7 we have Bishop to f6 and I
wish up to c3 King to e2
King to see for the Avengers King is
getting even deeper into the position
Knight to c5 and here we have E 5
because this wasn't really the best move
this 95 but there isn't really a good
move here I mean the knight would have
to go back and well eventually would
simply keep on improving his position he
did play Knight to c5 but this allows
the tactic now he is attacking this e 6
pawn but he want to just pushes at a 5
and the pawn cannot be captured as King
captures night and c5 is happening so
Kramnik play Knight to d7 and here well
we have eg after sandy for we have
Bishop Bishop to d8 this will be
preparing Bishop to b6 so d3 would check
by a van truck we have King to be 1
Bishop to b4 attacking that f2 point
so now Bishop to b6 this was the idea of
Bishop to d8 and we have Bishop captures
Knight captures with checked and out
King to d4 we have a Knight to c8
Knights to e5 rewriting the night so he
will be able to take this F to pawn nice
to East seven Knights to g4 now he is
attacking the f2 pawn king - we want
defending and now King to c3 the thread
is of course king C 2 and D 2 and D 1
Queen we have Knight to d5 check and
here event took place Kings to b3 King
to c2 was also possible this and I
before checked isn't really doing
anything we have King to d2 kramnik
doesn't really have any move to play
here any movie plays loses so he plays
King study two events plays Knight
captures on f2 we have h5 g captures on
h5 and now 1983 going for that f5 pawn
h4 we have Knight captures on f5 and now
h3 and in this position Vladimir Kramnik
resigned the game and and
Vasily von Schuch is the
he wins around three and he goes to
round four and well Magnus Carlsen did
yeah I mean they get kicked out of the
World Cup today as he lost his second
game to boo
he didn't lose the game he drew the game
as it was a bull found a nice rook
sacrifice and a perpetual check to
solidify his position after winning in
the previous game so yeah we won't have
a we won't have a match of course and
against divine choke in the finals but I
do hope we get a match of someone
against even choke in the finals so yeah
that's the game a beautiful game by one
Chuck really really really showed that
he still has it and winning with the
black pieces against Vladimir Kramnik is
is a is a huge thing that's that's
amazing so yeah I think all for watching
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here I'll see you soon
guys